all right vanessa i'm sorry to do it to
you but i have to i need to ask you
about the lost world and and
i never like asking the obvious question
or one that you've probably been asked
about quite a bit but i find that i'm
constantly in a position of defending
the gymnastics moment
so it's me it's making me let i have
strong feelings about that i have made
my case at great length but from your
perspective
what was your opinion when you read the
script and you realized what kelly's big
hero moment was going to be and then you
know years later looking back on it how
do you feel about the scene now
so the thing that's interesting is
because it was such a highly anticipated
film
i knew nothing about it when i booked it
i didn't find out that jeff goldblum was
playing my father until i was in a
wardrobe fitting and someone actually
slit and i was like wait huh like i had
no idea i just knew i was gonna be in
the movie you know and so
i never got a full script i had no idea
that that was actually happening and i
was
such a tomboy growing up very like
very female lots of female and male
energy going on when i was younger and i
just was like please give me a stunt
scene please give me something crazy to
do like i don't want to just be a kid in
this film like i want to do something
badass and then like i remember begging
them to let me fall like i was like i
don't need any like stunt gear just let
me do it i fall all the time just let me
do it i'm 13. and so when i saw that i
was like oh my gosh this is amazing
because i actually used to do gymnastics
so i was like this is so dope
i think it's incredible i think it's
really fun i think it's such a great
example for little girls out there
especially little women like women of
color back in the time you never really
saw a young woman of color in an action
film especially with such a significant
role helping to defeat the problem
and so
as i've gotten older it's been really
interesting
because there's the half of the people
who are like this would never happen in
the real world and it's like well that's
why we're in jurassic park
when's the last time you saw a raptor
running down the street it's not real
but there are also fans who have been
like do you realize that kelly is the
only person who has ever killed a
dinosaur without an actual weapon
and i was like
wait what i i'm today years old now
figuring that out so i stand by it i
think it's so badass i love it and
i would do it again i love that answer
gives me so much life right now i can't
even wait for that's like what am i even
saying anymore i was like i've been
talking for like two minutes does this
make sense i
i have spoken about that franchise to
such an extent i can't even begin to
tell you one more jurassic question for
you because i am a big believer that
she should have returned to the
franchise at one point in the jurassic
world iteration of it in your mind
doesn't have to be canon of course but
what do you think she's up to and i
guess maybe more specifically what do
you think her reaction to the events of
lost world were was it a situation where
it kind of you know kept a foot in the
dino situation for her or was she
terrified and just like went the other
way in my mind
i mean how do you
nearly die from dinosaurs and just walk
away like that was a fun trip you have
to change you know so
in my world i believe that
kelly
kind of reluctantly has [ __ ] like
followed in the footsteps of ian malcolm
you know after seeing what her dad
was has gone through and actually
knowing that it's real i don't believe
that with her curious spirit there was
any way she couldn't have gone in that
direction so in my world i believe that
kelly
put the uneven bars to rest and that's
when her love of science and genetics
really ratcheted up and so
i believe that there is a world where
kelly is probably
in the realm of
biogenetics and the stem world trying to
figure out how we got here what to do
and to be honest that would have been a
really fun
perspective to explore like it would
have been really fun to get a chance to
see kelly again as an adult you're
making me want like a spin-off series or
something now like i get messages every
day about it every day that's one of the
elements of the book that like i
understand why they pulled back on it
but there's so much material like rich
material to explore further in there i
love it